foreign
[Music]
having a comprehensive monitoring and
alerting service is a critical component
to maintaining a reliable and secure
Cloud deployment
however the standard notification
channel is available from these Services
email and SMS may not meet the needs of
your organization or deployment
in this case you can create a custom
channel to integrate an alternative
notification solution into your alerting
pipeline
in this video you'll learn how to use
cloud monitoring alerts with a custom
notification channel to Bringing
together alerts from across your
deployment to the channel of your choice
let's get started
a basic monitoring and learning pipeline
looks something like this
a cloud Ops admin creates alerting
policies to detect important events in
their services
when a policy is triggered it generates
an incident
this in turn generates a notification
which is sent to several notification
channels
to integrate a custom notification
channel into your alerting pipeline you
can use either of two approaches the
first option is to use a web hook
the second option uses Cloud run to
generate an API call to your preferred
notification service
the rest of this video walks you through
how to implement the latter option using
Cloud run at an API call
Cloud monitoring generates notifications
in Json using a schema which your
notification service may not understand
the simplest way to bridge this Gap is
to transform the message from cloud
monitoring to match the schema used by
your chosen notification service
at a high level this process involves
adding a new pub sub notification
Channel and attaching it to your Cloud
monitoring alert
sub will then push the message to a
cloud run service
the service transforms the message to
match your services schema
and then sends the transformed message
to the API of your notification service
to send notifications to your
notification service you will need two
service accounts with appropriate
permissions
first a monitoring service account with
identity and access management or IM
role Pub sub publisher to send messages
to your Pub sub topic be aware
Cloud monitoring creates the service
account for you so you just need to add
the Rope
second an invoker this is a new service
account with the cloud run invoker role
the pub sub channel will use this
account to push the notifications to
your Cloud run service
let's now look at the schema for an
example notification from cloud
monitoring
the schema is quite complex so I'll just
show the basic structure and the
pertinent sections related to the
transformation
the schema contains a version tag
your code should use this tag to check
that the message version is one your
code understands
the incident contains the resource
metrics metadata and policy information
for the incident
take note of the labels at various
levels they provide you a way to attach
application specific data to the metrics
to the policy or to the resource which
will end up in the incident
you can use this data as parameters for
your code
policy user labels can be set on each
alerting policy so are the most direct
place to set parameters
as an example if each team owns a set of
alerting policies you can use the policy
user labels to include data on which
team should get the notification in your
preferred notification service
team and service could be used to select
a chat room or channel in your
notification service where the people
who will act on the notification are
expecting the notification to land
now that you understand the cloud
monitoring notification message schema
let's look closer at your Cloud run code
Pub sub push subscriptions wrap the
notification in Json and post that to
the cloud run
your code must
read the message from Pub sub stored in
a dictionary or hash table
extract the data field in the message to
get the incident as a dictionary
use the incident data to construct a new
message to send your notification
Services API
and finally send the message and then
log the results
a quick note
when editing a pub sub notification
Channel there's a link send a test
notification which you can use anytime
to get sample data or test your code
you can then go to the subscriptions for
the pub sub topic and pull a message to
see the contents or allow your code to
receive the message and see what it does
to learn more about creating
notifications for your custom channels
follow the links in the video
description for documentation and detail
tutorials
thanks for watching
[Music]